Joe Biden jumps into the race House
Democrats seek more investigations and
the 2020 Democratic candidates
desperately seek attention i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
well this is my last podcast of the
weeks we better make it a good one and
today is the day joe biden officially
announcing his jump into the race we'll
get to his entire announcement we'll
analyze it break it down discuss where i
think he falls in the vast pantheon of
democratic candidates but first in 2008
the US national debt was 10 trillion
dollars today that is nearly 22 trillion
dollars it is rising like a hockey stick
if you don't think that we are sitting
on a house of cards you're living with
your head in the sand but since you're
listening to my podcast you are smarter
than the average bear so what exactly is
your plan can you afford another hits
your retirement like the last downturn
when the S&P dropped 50% you know it is
worthwhile diversifying your portfolio
no matter how you do it and one of the
things you should diversify into is
precious metals hedging against
inflation and against uncertainty and
instability with precious metals it's
pretty good idea gold is a safe haven
against uncertainty my savings plan is
diversified and yours should be as well
my company I trust with precious metal
purchases is Birch gold group right now
thanks to a little-known IRS tax law you
can even move your IRA or eligible 401k
into an IRA backed by physical gold and
silver which is perfect for people who
want to protect their hard-earned
retirement savings from any future
geopolitical uncertainty look back
historically when the bottom falls out
of everything else Gold does tend to
safeguard savings Birch gold group has
thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau contact
Birch gold group get a free information
kit on physical precious metals
today see if diversifying into gold and
silver makes sense for you text Ben to
47 47 47 again text Ben to 47 47 47 Ben
to 47 47 47 for the comprehensive 16
page free kit check it out Ben to 47 47
47 to check out my friends at Birch gold
group all righty so Joe Biden is now
officially into the race now there's a
lot of controversy earlier this week
over when he was going to jump in the
race but this had been the plan since
late last week he was going to drop in
online video and then next week he's
officially gonna launch his campaign in
Pittsburgh at some sort of Union Hall
which is smart
now the Joe Biden campaign is basically
apparently going to be run on the basis
that Joe Biden is a return to normalcy
I know it's weird Joe Biden on
or any definition would not be a return
to normalcy he's a gaffe machine who
says dumb things all the time
he's very controversial figure
historically speaking he has a long
record as a senator and as vice
president of the United States and if
the focus is on Joe Biden he doesn't
look nearly as good as when the focus is
not on Joe Biden and so Joe Biden is
gonna run a campaign that looks kind of
like Hillary Clinton's campaign in 2016
namely he's gonna put all the focus on
Donald Trump the entire focus is going
to be on Donald Trump now it didn't work
for Hillary the reason that it didn't
work for Hillary Clinton is because
Hillary herself was a widely hated
figure she was much more hated than Joe
Biden ever has been mainly because Joe
Biden has been a political afterthought
for most of his career even when he was
vice president joe biden was never
considered a political force he was
considered a career political guy who
had failed a couple of times at running
for president completely blew up in 2008
on platform so yeah the idea that Joe
Biden is as threatening as Hillary
Clinton is simply not true so the
question is can Hillary Clinton's
campaign win without Hillary Clinton
that's really the question and after
several years of president Trump being
president is the American public finally
going to engage in a referendum on Trump
or will this become a referendum on Joe
Biden now as I have said for a long time
about this election cycle if this is a
referendum on Democrats Democrats lose
if this is a referendum on President
Trump he is not a popular president he's
in bad shape if it's a referendum on
President Trump Joe Biden the thinking
seems to be will be
what would create a referendum on
President Trump simply because most
Americans are kind of comfortable with
the old quirky guy who is VP under
Barack Obama by polling data anyway now
there's a couple of problems with this
one is that Joe Biden is a human with a
record that Joe Biden actually has a
pretty long record of his own we'll get
into that in just one second the other
thing is that people seem to have
forgotten that Barack Obama was ever
president I know it feels like it's been
35 years since Barack Obama was
president but really in reality has only
been a couple of years since Barack
Obama was president and Joe Biden was
there for all of it and so as we will
see I think there are a couple of
fruitful lines of counter-attack that
President Trump could use against Joe
Biden suffice it to say that in the
early polling the first polling Joe
Biden against Donald Trump Joe Biden has
a significant edge on Donald Trump
according to a morning consult this
morning as Biden prepares to
enter the race a morning consult
political poll conducted April 19
through 20 first among 2,000 registered
voters found Biden leading the president
by 8 percentage points in a hypothetical
matchup 42% to 34% which leaves a bunch
of voters on the table you may be saying
yourself wait a second 42 and 34 that is
only 76% where the other 24% of voters
and the answer is they haven't decided
yet which is not great news for
president Trump frankly because the fact
that there were a lot of undecideds
going into the 2016 election was good
news for President Trump because again
the focus was on Hillary Clinton the
fact that President Trump is the
incumbent president and he is riding at
34% in polls against Joe Biden is not
good news for the president not gonna
sugarcoat that Biden has a significant
edge over Trump among women 17 points
millenials 22 points and independents 10
points that last one is the one that
matters of course there's gonna be a
massive gender gap for President Trump
that always has been
Millennials do despise President Trump
by polling data it was one of my great
fear is when Trump was elected is that
he was gonna poison the well with
Millennials among independents that's
really where the question lies and
independence if this were Bernie versus
Trump it would look a lot closer because
independents would look at Bernie and
they'd say okay well as much as Bernie
wants this to be a referendum on Trump
Bernie is a human with views and those
views are radical Joe Biden is sort of
seen as a wet dishrag and so if it's a
wet dishrag versus trump that doesn't
favor Trump actually Trump garnering
roughly 1/3 of the vote in the early had
to heads has pales in comparison to the
last incumbent president at this point
in 2012 Barack Obama led Mitt Romney by
several points he was pulling
consistently in the mid to high 40s even
after he got blown up in the 2010
election wave Biden has also held a
consistent lead in morning consult
weekly tracking among likely Democratic
primary voters 3 in 10 say that Biden is
their top pick followed by 24% for
Vermont senator Bernie Sanders now I've
been saying for a while I think that Joe
Biden's best day is his first day and so
this is his best day congratulations Joe
Biden this right here is your best day
the reason it is his best day is because
nobody is looking at his record today
nobody is looking back at all the stupid
things that he has said he has not been
on the campaign trail for even a moment
yet and that means that the only message
we have from Joe Biden at this point
is his video message so let's jump into
Joe Biden's video message so he releases
a three-minute video we're gonna analyze
it in full and then we're gonna talk
about how exactly all of this plays into
the 20/20 feel so Joe Biden's campaign
message is him talking into camera
juxtaposed with footage of
Charlottesville now you knew the
Democrats were gonna use Charlottesville
to its fullest effect of course they
were it was Trump's lowest moments of
his presidency now I know listen there I
know there are a lot of people who are
trying on the right to engage in what I
consider to be a revisionist history
about what President Trump said about
Charlottesville he did not say there
were good Nazis but what he did say is
that there were good people on both
sides of the Marches in Charlottesville
this was simply not true the people who
are marching in Charlottesville around
the statue it was not a bunch of nice
people who showed up to March with
Richard Spencer this thing was
identified as unite the right rally that
was led by all right white supremacists
and when President Trump said this it
was a huge mistake
he knew it at the time he apologized for
it then he moved back in the other
direction I'm gonna play you the full
clip of President Trump talking about
people are trying to say he meant there
were people on both both good people on
both sides of the Confederate statue
debate if that's what he had said I
would have not only had no problem with
it I would have agreed with it but
that's not really what he said when he
said is there were good people marching
who's specifically referring to that
Friday night so here's what the
president said and you had a group and
the other and they came at each other
with clubs and it was vicious and it was
horrible and it was a horrible thing to
watch
I think there's blame on both sides and
I have no doubt about it and you don't
have any doubt about it either but you
also had people that were very fine
people on both sides you had people in
that group that were there to protest
the taking down of to them a very very
important statue and the renaming of a
park from Robert eleaf to another name
okay so that last okay so that last
comment people are now taking that out
of context on the right and suggesting
that Trump was not talking about the
protesters who showed up he was talking
about writ large Confederate statues
that is not accurate okay that is just
not what he said at the time and so I am
I am loath to rewrite history in favor
of President Trump
specifically because that again I want
to read you the entire transcript okay
here's what he said there's the entire
transcript
I think there's blame on both sides you
look at both sides I think there is
blame objectively on both sides I have
no doubt about it you don't have any
doubt about it if you reported it
accurately you would say the neo-nazi
started this thing they showed up in
Charlottesville excuse me they didn't
put themselves down as neo-nazis he had
some very bad people in that group he
also had some very fine people on both
sides you had people in that group
excuse me excuse me I saw the same
pictures as you did you had people in
that group that were there to protest
the taking down of to them a very very
important statue and the renaming of a
park from Robert II leads to another
name and then he moved on to his
discussion of generalized statues and
taking down to the statues an issue
about which I largely agree with
president Trump but I don't I'm not
gonna buy the rewriting of history just
for partisan purposes so that is not
what President Trump said when he says
find people on both sides he was not
specifically talking about the
generalized debate a proposition with
which I agree he was talking I mean he
referred to the pictures of the violence
he talked specifically about the night
that he was talking about I've yet to
identify the nice people who are
marching with Richard Spencer that night
hey end of story
so that is a fair hit it is also fair to
note that the Democrats have then taken
this and blown this up into president
Trump has widespread sympathies for the
all right that is not true he is
disassociated from the alt-right
forcibly so and he's fired everyone in
the White House was even remotely
associated with the outright I'm looking
at you Steve Danon
the President of the United States has
been more strongly against anti-semitism
than any president in recent memory he's
been more against anti-israel sentiment
than any president in recent memory and
the Democrats as we'll see who are
calling upon President Trump and trying
to label him an anti-semite these are
the same people who are defending ill
Han Omar an open anti-semite at the same
time so I am NOT somebody who takes
winking and nodding at the alt-right
with a grain of salt I think that was
very bad I think President Trump did
that early in his presidency I think he
did it during his campaign but that is
not what he is right now
now with that said is it a smart tactic
for Democrats to use Charlottesville
against the president of course it
forces him onto the defensive now we're
gonna get Republicans rehashing those
comments for the next week that's really
not what they should be doing so we're
gonna play Joe Biden's ad in just one
second we'll discuss the ad and then
we'll discuss how President Trump really
should respond to Joe Biden
as Biden jumps into the campaign first
let's talk about your stress level with
stress and anxiety many people often
feel exhausted during the day then it's
time to go to bed you can't fall asleep
well this is where a calm comes in we
are partnering with calm the number one
app to help you reduce your anxiety and
stress and help you sleep better more
than 40 million people around the world
have downloaded it if you head over to
calm calm / pen you'll get it 25% off a
comprar Miam subscription which includes
guided meditations on issues like
anxiety stress and focus including a
brand new meditation each day there are
also sleep stories which are bedtime
stories for adults designed to help you
relax your heads in magical lavender
fields of southern France with Stephen
Fry or explore the moonlit jungles of
Africa with Leona Lewis you'll be out
like a light you can even use this on
your kids by the way they even have
soothing music and more right now my
listeners ben shapiro listeners get a
25% off a calm premium subscription at
calm calm slash band that is c alm calm
/ban get unlimited access to all of
calms content today at comb calm slash
man get calm stop stressing I know
everybody is too stressed out and this
is why you should be using calm check
them out right now and get 25% off a
premium subscription and calm calm / Ben
C ALM calm / Ben ok so finally at long
last president
okay so Vice President Joe Biden jumping
into the race his dad as I say is
focused on Charlottesville here's what
it sounds like
Charlottesville Virginia is home to the
author of one of the great documents in
human history we know by heart we hold
these truths to be self-evident that all
men are created equal endowed by their
creator with certain inalienable rights
we've heard us so often it's almost a
cliche but it's who we are we haven't
always lived up to these ideals
Jefferson himself didn't but we have
never before walked away from them ok so
very important thing that Joe Biden is
doing right here strategically speaking
and it is separating him off from his
own party I have been saying in my book
tour I've been saying for a long time
there's the difference in vision in this
country one vision of America is that
America has these wonderful founding
ideals and we have not always lived up
to them and the other vision of America
is that America is founded on terrible
horrible no good very bad ideals and
that we have lived up to them and we
have to abandon those ideals Joe Biden
is running squarely in that first
now there may be a silent majority of
Democrats who still agree with that
first lane which would be great I mean
those are the same people who I am
trying to appeal to too because I think
that that's an important message that
America is inherently great but what Joe
Biden is actually saying is make America
great again right he's saying make
America great again because America was
already great America had great ideals
we haven't lived like he's this is a
conservative message that he's pushing
out there right now how is that gonna
play in an intersectional primary where
every other candidate in the Democratic
Party is complaining that America is
inherently rooted in evil in racism
sexism bigotry homophobia how is that
going to play Joe Biden is running
squarely in the moderate lane right now
I remember there's only the first 30
seconds of his candidacy so what happens
when he comes under attack does he
abandon all of that remember this is
smart what Joe Biden is doing here he's
running the Barack Obama 2008 campaign
not the Barack Obama 2012 campaign
is that gonna play in the Democratic
Party of Bernie Sanders and Kamala
Harris and Ilhan Omar I have my doubts
Joe Biden continues Charlotte was also
home to a defining moment for this
nation in the last few years
it was there in August of 2017 we saw
Klansmen and white supremacists and
neo-nazis come out in the open they're
crazed faces illuminated by torches
veins and bulging and burying the fangs
of racism chanting the same anti-semitic
vile heard across Europe in the 30
and they were met by a courageous group
of Americans in a violent clash ensue
and a brave young woman lost her life
and that's when we heard the words the
present United States that stunned of
the world and shocked the conscience of
this nation she said there were quote
some very fine people on both sides okay
so this is where Joe Biden is making his
pitch right Joe that Berta that Donald
Trump has undermined the spirit of
America with charlotte's Ville he is
taking for granted a couple of things
and I think those things cannot be taken
for granted in a second I'm gonna
explain what he's taking for granted and
why I think that he's overstating his
case okay so what he is saying from the
very beginning right is he makes that
conservative pitch that conservative
pitches that America is founded on these
great ideals we haven't always lived up
to them and then Charlottesville is a
betrayal of those ideals okay agree with
that he's taking a couple things for
granted thing number one that he is
taking for granted the idea that
Charlottesville is indicative of a broad
widespread mentality among Americans I
do not think that is true I do not think
most Americans think that is true he is
in danger of stepping into the same
minefield that Hillary Clinton stepped
into when she suggested that all
supporters of Donald Trump or
effectively white supremacist and
deplorable 's remember that she called
everybody deplorable who supported
Donald Trump in the last election cycle
this is a huge mistake
because the vast majority of people who
support Donald Trump do not do so
because of Charlottesville they do not
do so because they think that Donald
Trump is in favor of white supremacy so
Joe Biden is in serious danger of
falling into that trap problem number
two Joe Biden happens to have picked as
his lead indicator of trumps evil this
March which was replete with the
anti-semitism one problem the Democratic
Party is steeped in anti-semitism at the
moment the first time Joe Biden mentions
this don't you think that President
Trump is going to say to him okay Joe
what do you have to say about Ilhan Omar
Rasheeda Talib anything like any words
on Ilhan Omar and Rasheeda Talib I'm the
most pro-israel president in American
history I have Jewish grandchildren do
you really believe that I'm an
anti-semite you've known me my entire
life do you believe I'm an anti-semite
and if you're saying I'm soft on
anti-semitism let me ask you a question
vice-president why is it that you served
under an administration that endorsed
the Iran deal and lied about the
American public in order to do so why
did you work for an administration
though so wildly anti-israel their
Defense Department was instructed not to
provide weaponry to
rayul in the middle of the Gaza war why
do you side with a democratic party that
has made excuses for Ilhan Omar a raging
and open anti-semite and Rashid it to
leave a raging and open anti-semite any
wars on that whatsoever
my Trump's got some pretty good
comebacks here and Joe Biden is hoping
an opening himself up wide to them now
again he is hoping that his focus on
Trump means that Trump becomes the
subject of the Publix referendum but Joe
Biden is very vulnerable in these areas
as well and Trump has not yet begun to
fight let's continue with the ad find
people on both sides
those words the president United States
assigned a moral equivalence between
those spreading hate than those of the
courage to stand against it and in that
moment I knew the threat to this nation
was unlike any I had ever seen in my
lifetime
like any she has seen in the lifetime
dude lived through the 60s in the 1970s
he came out in favor of segregation to a
certain extent he suggested that forced
busing which was a bad idea was a bad
idea not because it was ineffective and
not because if force children to shuttle
hours on end on buses but it was bad
because it might undermine black
segregationist pride man this is
something that Joe Biden actually said
during the 1970s according to the
Washington Examiner here's a quote from
1975 he said that the concept of busing
that we are going to integrate people so
that they all have the same access and
learned to grow up with one another and
all the rest is a rejection of the whole
movement of black pride said Biden
desegregation was a rejection of the
entire black awareness concept where
black is beautiful black culture should
be studied and the cultural awareness of
the importance of their own identity
their own individuality is that
something Joe Biden was saying way back
when so this is the worst time he's ever
seen for American racism truly all
Donald Trump has to do to respond to
this is show video of Ferguson and
Baltimore this is the right now this is
the worst this is what he said this is
where you said I have to draw the line
let's let's not be too naive about this
basically Joe Biden decided he was gonna
run for president the moment that Donald
Trump was elected and he was the next
guy on the short list for Democrats
that's all he seriously considered
running in 2016 and only when he didn't
receive Barack Obama's endorsement did
he decide not to hilariously enough by
the way a lot of people been wondering
is Barack Obama going to endorse Biden
the answer apparently is no for the
moment apparently but Biden's people are
out there I kid you not walking around
and saying with a straight face that Joe
Biden was offered Obama's endorsement
and rejected it because he wants to see
how his candidacy plays on his own sure
and I turned down an NBA contract
yesterday because I don't want to
humiliate all the other players I want
to show my magic bball skills just on
the court by myself I want to show you
hacking 360 windmill dunk without you
know having to humiliate the
seven-footers in the NBA other than that
I totally would have taken the NBA
contract sure Joe Biden sure okay Joe
Biden continues I wrote at the time they
were in the battle for the soul of this
nation well that's even more true today
we are in the battle for the soul of
this nation I believe history will look
back on four years of this president and
all the embraces as an aberrant moment
in time but if we give Donald Trump
eight years in the White House he will
forever
and fundamentally alter the character
this nation who we are and I cannot
stand by and watch that happen
the character of the nation so this is
in fact the best attack on president
Trump because the economy is good his
policy has been good the best attack on
him was always going to be a character
attack and Biden is not making the
character attack about the facts that
the dude slept around the porn stars or
something he's making the character
attack about he's changed who we are
this is his entire campaign now there
are some people who find this
inspirational and they feel like okay
this is the return to normalcy Trump is
an aberration something weird on the
other hand on the other hand Barack
Obama you sees the who we are nonsense
all the time he would suggest who we are
is not people who get upset about the
Ferguson riots who we are are people who
wonder about the root causes of the
Ferguson riots he would constantly be
using the phrase who we are to describe
basically his own political viewpoint it
gets very tiresome very quickly right
now as I say the shine is still on Joe
Biden Joe Biden is still a guy with
gravitas served as vice president for
eight years by most accounts of people
who know him is a nice guy but with all
of that said his campaign is not gonna
be this for the next two years his
campaign for the next few years can't be
well we're gonna go back to a better
time in America when I was VP because
was it a better time or were we just as
divided and the economy was worse where
we just as divided and you were shipping
billions of dollars in cash to the
Iranians there's a lot of vulnerability
here launch videos always look pretty
good and I will say the Joe Biden is
doing something different in his launch
video he's talking about the character
of the country which lends a gravitas
and a weight to his video that doesn't
exist in for example mayor Pete's video
which is all about hi I'm mayor beat and
I'm from
you're not getting that from Biden
because we all know his record but I am
not sure it's gonna play over the course
of two years as well as Biden thinks it
well in a second we'll get to the rest
of Biden's campaign launch video and
we'll talk about how it plays for the
rest of the Democrats first you've heard
me talk about how ring is reinventing
home security with doorbells cameras
even an alarm you can install yourself
now they're reinventing the neighborhood
watch they have a new app they created
called neighbors by ring remember the
neighborhood watch been around for a
while helps you know when there's crime
happening in your area well now ring has
something similar they've reinvented the
neighborhood watch with the neighbors
app it's like the new neighborhood watch
on your phone people taking stuff off
porches trying to wear nobs late at
night missing dogs the neighbors app
sends real-time notifications to your
phone whenever one of your neighbors
posts a heads-up about something that's
going on which helps keep you informed
the neighbors app by ring is completely
free anyone can join even if they don't
own it rings vice I've downloaded the
neighbors app I do check it regularly to
see what the crime rates are like in my
area burn crime rate specifically
anecdotal things that are happening in
my area I'm shocked by the amount of
crime in my area frankly because mayor
Garcetti in Los Angeles is terrible at
his job in any case you need to go check
out the neighbors half right now check
out the neighbors app yourself the
easiest way to get it going
is ring.com forward slash Shapiro that
is ring.com
forward slash Shapiro make your
neighborhood safer today with the
neighbors app by ring that's ring comm
/sh appear oh it's great app ring has
lots of great products go check them out
right now ringing comm forward slash
Shapiro all righty so we're continuing
with Joe Biden's had so the case that he
has made thus far America was already
great a very conservative case
Charlottesville was a betrayal of that
Donald Trump is Charlottesville
that connection is specious and then
finally he gets to and that's why I
jumped in the race because I felt like
this is a crisis unlike any other which
of course is what every politician
always says it's the most important
election of our lifetime I needed to
jump in because we were at crisis point
we're not a crisis point this isn't the
most important election of our lifetime
other than it's an election that is
happening now and you can't vote in the
one from 2016 in any case here is Joe
Biden continuing the core values of this
nation our standing in the world
our very democracy everything that has
made America America's at stake that's
why today I'm announcing my candidacy
for President of the United States
folks America is an idea an idea that's
stronger than any arm you're bigger than
any ocean more powerful than any
dictator or tyrant it gives hope to the
most desperate people on earth it
guarantees that everyone is treated with
dignity and gives hate no safe harbor it
instills in every person in this country
the belief that no matter where you
start in life there's nothing you can't
achieve if you work at it that's what we
believe and above all else that's what's
at stake in this election we can't
forget what happened in Charlotte show
even more important we have to remember
who we are this is America
Hey and that's his entire ad now here's
the thing about that ad there's not a
word in that ad just reading it there's
not a worden in that ad aside from his
characterization of this is the greatest
crisis we've ever faced and
charlottesville is a marathon all this
kind of stuff and Trump is fundamental
all that stuff is wrong but the main
message of the ad I agree with all of
that you probably agree with all that
that's why I say Biden is running in the
moderate lane even though his historic
record is not particularly moderate he
is running in that Lane right that lasts
a perfect example so Joe Biden when he
talks about America as an idea and all
the great things we've done in the past
the stock footage that he uses his stock
footage of Marines landing on the
beaches during Normandy or at
Guadalcanal and then he juxtaposes that
with MLK and the civil rights marchers
now there's a thing that all the other
Democratic candidates have done in their
video the joe biden did not do in this
video hey all the other Democratic
candidates then flashed to some sort of
gay pride parade or something right then
they flash to the the rainbow flag on
the wall of the White House or something
Joe Biden specifically does not do that
that's a choice I promise you somebody
in his campaign said to him Joe we don't
want that in there why because you used
to oppose gay marriage we don't want
that in there why because you are trying
to appeal to blue-collar voters in
Pennsylvania Wisconsin and Michigan not
to Upper East Side liberals in New York
and Washington DC and Los Angeles I
promise you that something that happened
so Joe Biden is running that campaign
now how is that campaign going to play
with the with the progressive wing of
the Democratic Party Biden is hoping
that the progressive Savage each other
that there are 10 people in that Lane
he's the only person in the moderate
lane and he walks away at the nomination
that's not a terrible strategy it really
is not but all guns are now going to
train themselves on Joe Biden Joe Biden
is everything that the that the radical
base of the Democratic Party despises
not just dislikes despises so for
example the Justice Democrats came out
today and they put out a tweet saying
they are not going to endorse Joe Biden
they said quote Joe Biden is out of
touch with the center of energy in the
Democratic Party today now notice that
language of the center of energy and I
think that's correct
the center of energy is not with Joe
Biden and his sort of moderate view of
America as a fundamentally great place
that we have not always lived up to
that's a conservative view
most people on the left do not believe
in this so they say Democrats future
medicare-for-all green New Deal free
college rejecting corporate money ending
mass incarceration and deportation right
that is what they say the future is Joe
Biden voted in favor of the Iraq war he
voted for bankruptcy Reform Act he voted
for mass incarceration in fact he helped
author it in 1994 he voted against
school desegregation and against
marriage equality according to them now
he didn't actually vote against school
desegregation he voted against forced
busing that's not the same thing as
desegregation forced integration and
desegregation are not the same thing
legally speaking but when he says that
they voted against marriage equality but
it in favor of traditional marriage he
invited in favor of of the I believe in
the 1990s the Defense of Marriage Act so
in any case the the Joe Biden the Joe
Biden record will be up for debate here
among Democrats now here's the thing in
a if we just went straight to the
general election
you'd have to favor Joe Biden II be the
odds-on favorite against Donald Trump in
a primary however Joe Biden occupies the
space that Donald Trump occupied so in a
in a primary space Joe Biden basically
is Trump Trump in the general is this
larger-than-life figure who is the
incumbent and the referendum is going to
be on him that's at least the democratic
theory in the Democratic primaries Biden
is the larger-than-life figure and all
of the focus is going to be on him and
the problem for Joe Biden is that he has
never with stood folk as well Joe Biden
has always failed to withstand the scars
of battle this is why he failed in 1988
and had to drop out of replayed RISM
scandal so Bernie Sanders is gonna be
the first person to go after Joe Biden
obviously and Bernie's allies are
preparing the fight according to the
hill Sanders has been more of a liberal
liberal policy visionary championing
policies that were initially regarded by
colleagues as fringe ideas these
concepts were later embraced by leading
members of the Democratic caucus such as
raising the minimum wage to 15 bucks an
hour and providing free college
education former colleagues describe
Biden and Sanders as polar opposites in
terms of personalities and interacting
with fellow senators Biden 76 is
gregarious and sociable he was always
eager to work a room strike up a
friendly conversation or reassure a
colleague who's feeling down a retail
politician to his core Biden always
wanted to know what was
fellow senators mind Sanders by contrast
was focused on policy often so wrapped
up in his thoughts he seemed oblivious
to his colleagues he was seen as
consumed by ambitious plans to fight
wealth and equality and push the
national debate to the left but
uninterested in the personal lives of
fellow senators who do you think the
base is going to resonate to if you hate
Trump like despised from if you're a
Trump hater who do you think you're
gonna go for Joe Biden a guy who's kind
of amiable but not necessarily as
hard-edged or Bernie Sanders who's going
to yell and scream and rant and rave
about Donald Trump or Kamala Harris
who's a prosecutor Democrats have a lot
of choices in these primaries I'm not
sure that Joe Biden stands up to
scrutiny that's a very conservative
campaign launch video and frankly I'm
sort of astonished that's the direction
that he went especially because he's now
going to have to defend his record
Senator Dianne Feinstein has already
come out and said that Biden would have
handled he Clarence Thomas Anita Hill
hearings differently if he could do it
all over again
he's gonna spend the first month of his
campaign apologizing for his entire
record that's what Joe Biden is gonna do
is that a solid launch strategy
basically the only reason he's famous is
the reason he's going to be apologizing
I don't see this as working well for
Biden I think he's gonna launch he'll be
strong at launch and then it's all
downhill from there okay in just a
second we're gonna get two more on Joe
Biden how the other Democrats are
reacting where things stand right now
but first it can be a little frustrating
I know especially if you are in a hurry
or you're running late to find yourself
in a railway crossing waiting for our
train I know it takes forever and it
feels like the the arms of the of the
railway crossing comes down and then
you're just sitting there for 35 minutes
waiting for the train to pass if the
signals are going and the train is not
even there yet sometimes you might feel
a bit tempted to try and sneak across
the tracks do not do this do not do this
don't try to outrun a train guys trains
are going a lot faster than you expect
them to be and they cannot stop even if
an engineer hits the brakes right away
seeing it coming it can take a train
over a mile to stop by that time what
used to be your car is just a crushed
hunk of metal and what used to be you is
not you anymore
the point is you don't know how quickly
the train is going to ride so please for
the love of Pete sit there and wait
don't be stupid the train can't stop
even if it sees you and the results
could be your doom
so if the signals are on the train is on
its way you need to just remember one
thing you need to stop the train cannot
okay this is I know it sounds like an
obvious message but it's something that
some people are missing okay just stop
don't try to outrun a train guys bad bad
idea you're not Superman just stop and
wait okay so in a second we'll get to
the other Democratic candidates and
we'll show how all of the Canon are now
going to train on Joe Biden but first
you're gonna have to go and subscribe
for $9.99 a month you can get a
subscription to daily wire calm when you
do you get the rest of our show live to
get the rest of the Andrew Clavin show
live the rest of the Michael Noel's show
live the rest and that wall show live
you also get two additional hours of us
every day well these next week when I
will be back on duty full-time you get
all of those wonders you get to
correspond with me in the mailbag also
you get our Sunday special on Saturday
this week we have Allie Stuckey the host
of relatable on blaze TV Allie's wonder
a conservative millennial I'm sure
you've seen her stuff she's on our
Sunday special this weekend get that on
Saturday if interested here's what that
sounded like unfortunately kids are seen
as this kind of accessory that they're a
burden to the rest of your life then I
just hope there are women who can wake
up and realize you know I'm not enough I
don't have it all in myself to make sure
that I'm fulfilled and satisfied I
actually have to give of myself in order
to do that
all righty so you can go check that out
and get it on Saturday when your
subscriber also check us out at YouTube
or iTunes first of all I want to thank
everybody we are apparently number two
podcasts in America like among all
podcasts for the last month we can make
ourselves number one so tell all of your
friends about it go check us out at
YouTube or iTunes download it leave us a
review we always appreciate it we're the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
all righty so joe biden's launch video
it seems like it's being fairly well
received by members of the media but
it's very early as of yet there are
already some of the base members of the
Democratic Party who are getting upset
not just the just the Justice Democrats
people like Bakari sellers so Bakari
Bakari sellers came out on Twitter and
he immediately started slapping Joe
Biden for his criminal justice record he
was the CNN commentator he says Joe
Biden you were the author of the 94
crime belt its champion its number one
cheerleader this bill has led to mass
incarceration and specifically targeted
black and brown people what are your
plans to unravel the damage you helped
to cause without Barack Obama endorsing
Joe Biden this will be the lead point of
attack for people like Kamala Harris who
is already fundraising over Biden's
entry into the race saying she welcomes
him there it'll be a fun debate also she
needs money the problem for Joe Biden is
that if you take away his support in the
minority community he's running behind
Bernie Sanders hey Joe Biden is earning
outside support from the black community
right now in fact he's earning a
plurality of the black vote right now in
polling data if that starts to chip away
and that will be the first area where
people seek to attack him if that starts
to bleed away to a combination of Cory
Booker and Kamala Harris both of whom
have to train themselves on Joe Biden
it's gonna be a problem for Joe Biden
meanwhile like right now as I say right
now Biden is popular like by polling
number women are studs women still like
Biden black folks still like Biden I
wonder if that's the story two months
from now and the real reason of course
that Joe Biden is doing well is because
if you look at Democratic polls one of
the things that you see is that the
number one priority is defeating Trump
and they think that he is the most
electable they're trying to forecast his
electability electability versus
President Trump or over time as attacks
start to mount up against him and if
Donald Trump starts to hit him that
could change you can see that the Donald
Trump is already lowering his boom on
Joe Biden he tweeted out early this
morning about Joe Biden he said it said
welcome to the race sleepy Joe sleepy
Joe I only hope you have the
intelligence along in doubt to wage a
successful primary campaign it will be
nasty you'll be dealing with paper who
truly have some very sick and demented
ideas but if you make it I will see you
at the starting gate
so there's the president welcoming Joe
Biden to the race I have to say not
super happy with sleepy Joe as a moniker
I'm not it's it's it really does lack
like there's something that have really
had pizzazz like sloppy steve was really
good about steve Bannon and of course
creepy joe is right there for the taking
in fact creepy joe is already trending
on twitter even though trump didn't use
it they're a bunch of crazy joe right
like there's plenty of trumps favorite
adjectives you could use to describe joe
biden i'm not sure why sleepy is the
thing as though it's a contest of energy
now I know that that Biden is trying to
appear sober but the fact is that for a
man his age dude has a pretty good
energy level so I'm not sure that that's
a winning moniker better moniker is
necessary mr. president so let's go back
to the drawing board again the major
draw for Biden is the Democrats think he
can be Trump by polling data that
obviously appears to be a not
implausible case you're seeing the only
other Democrat in the race who realizes
this is apparently a Buddha judges that
electability matters so Pete Buddha
judge is attacking Bernie Sanders he
says Bernie Sanders can't win and that's
why you shouldn't vote for Bernie
Sanders now I think that he is probably
right but I don't think that those votes
then turn to pee poo to judge a mayor of
South Bend Indiana who has fewer
constituents than I have family members
in any case here's Pete Buddha judge
suggesting that soapy Buddha judge
suggested that he doesn't think that
Bernie can win a general election so
vote for me he said quote I have a hard
time seeing the coalition ultimately
coming together there he said that
people are refreshed by the novelty and
boldness of Sanders idea but they're now
less excited so Buddha judges is trying
to go after Bernie and savage his vote
I'm surprised that Buddha judge has not
gone after Biden I think he will I think
he will and the beneficiary by the way
will be Bernie Sanders by polling data
if people don't vote for Biden who is
their second choice Bernie Sanders now
the rest of the Democratic Party is
trying desperately to gain attention
from a media that is struggling to keep
up with the vast number of Democrats who
are running Elizabeth Warren trying to
grab attention she went to some sort of
women in politics events where she
suggested of course that black women are
dying in childbirth more often because
of racism in medical industry even
though she has suggested no solutions to
said racism in the medical industry and
even though the vast majority of female
death and childbirth is due to low birth
weight or
existing health problems she's
immediately going to label the entire
health industry racist based on
something here she is doing that routine
in a desperate search for attention
well countries around the world have had
more and more mothers surviving
childbirth here in the United States
were one of only a handful of countries
where it's actually gone down and there
is a specific problem as you rightly
identify for women of color who are
three to four times more likely to die
in childbirth and here's the thing even
after we do the adjustments for income
for education this is true across the
board okay well that may be true across
the board you know where else it's true
in Europe so she's just contrast in
America's birth rates and death rates
with European birth rates and death
rates you know it's true in Europe black
women die at a higher rate in childbirth
minority women die at a higher rate in
childbirth
then white women do in Europe as well so
that may suggest that the problem does
not lie with american-style racism in
particular but she's trying to make a
headline and hey more power to her all
the Democrats are trying to make a
headline bado is trying to make a
headline as well in a second we're gonna
get to the rest of the Democrats that
the she the people convention she the
people okay anyway bata desperately
seeking attention too bad it's all been
stolen by Peter Budaj a Jewish here is
bata talking about we need an Equal
Rights Amendment because my hands won't
stop moving bra a minimum wage is not
going to be enough especially when it
comes to women of color women alone in
this country are paid eighty cents on
average what a man is paid for the same
job but african-american women 61 cents
of what a man is paid Latinas 53 cents
of what a man is paid we also need an
Equal Rights Amendment ratified in this
country so that no woman can be
discriminated against on any basis
whatsoever hindering and pandering and
lies in pandering Hispanic women are not
making 53 cents on the dollar black
women are not making whatever was sixty
cents on the dollar none of this is true
and when you remove all of the confounds
people are basically making what people
make but
Beto's pandering to Kamala Harris is in
the pandering business see here's the
thing about Joe Biden if he can stick
with
his original campaign plan if he can
stick with the moderation and the non
pandering not only do I think that he
runs the gamut in the primary I think he
wins the nominate I think it wins the
nomination I think he's a very strong
candidate for the presidency I think
that if he campaigns as a moderate and
he's able to withstand the pressure
it'll be fine but I don't know that he
can do that because he's got the entire
Democratic Party like a pack of hyenas
savaging him from every side coming up
you just wait for it by the end of the
weekend this will be the message because
the Democrats are too busy savaging each
other this is the entertaining part of
the primaries for Republicans listen to
Kamala Harris talking about how we need
to let young people who sold weed off
the off-the-chain from prison they
shouldn't be in prison anymore and they
should actually be at the front of the
line to get jobs in the weed
dispensaries this is such an amazingly
stupid case and Kamala Harris is a
former prosecutor running away from her
own record my goodness these people are
bad at their jobs people who
historically were arrested for drugs
marijuana sales were young men young men
of color now this is one of the fastest
growing money-making industries in our
country and the very young men who who
were trying to make money doing the same
thing but got criminalized and have now
been branded felons for life
are excluded from the economic
opportunities that are now available
because of this new industry so part of
what has to happen is there have to be
policies in place that look at the
background and actually do the work of
saying that some of those young men
should be first in line to get the jobs
that are available okay and the big
cheers that go up from the radical after
this idiotic proposal two questions one
who put those people in prison Kamala
you're a prosecutor who put those people
in prison - I don't think the reason
that people went into the weeds the weed
dispensing business when it was illegal
in the state of California I don't think
they did that because they were just
young entrepreneurs who are looking for
a new way to break into a growing
business I think they knew it was an
easy way to make money because it turns
out that people who commit crimes of one
type are very likely to have committed
crimes of another type the same people
this is like saying that everybody who
ran booze during Prohibition those who
definitely be the be the best bartenders
or maybe they were criminals and they
were using the facts that booze was
illegal as a way to make money
if they cannot make money at a weed
dispensary in the same way they were
dealing weed they will find another way
to make money it's just it's so silly
but I get this is the new Democratic
Party Cory Booker doing the pandering
routine as well
he says he'll have a female running mate
I always find this highly amusing when
men say I love women so much that I will
have a female running mate I love women
so much that I need a woman to be
subservient to me on my ticket I think
that women deserve political power so
much that I a man should have the most
political power and a woman can have the
warm bucket of spit job here's Cory
Booker with his crazy eyes making that
case the question is given here it is
why I pledge to have a woman running
mate I will have a woman running mate to
me it's really clear that we do that yay
okay fine so why don't you drop out and
endorse Kirsten Gillibrand you think
women should have more power I have a
very easy way to make this happen
just drop out and endorse canola Harris
it's pretty amazing
now as I mentioned before Joe Biden is
campaigning on the basis that Democrats
have the moral high ground in America
because of President Trump here's cory
booker blowing up that that moral high
ground suggesting that Ilhan omar is a
wonderful wonderful woman and that all
attacks on her are reprehensible the
criticisms of congressman Omar what
Donald Trump has been saying about her
is reprehensible
it is trafficking in Islamophobia and it
should be condemned by everyone this
kind of selective condemnation should be
a chorus of people condemning okay now
do L Hannah Mars anti-semitism so if you
criticize Doha Omar this makes you an
Islamophobe but Phil Han minor says the
Druze are in control of everything then
that is fine and the Democrat this is
the new democratic party this is the new
democratic party at least this is what
the politicians think the new democratic
party is now maybe Joe Biden runs for
that silent majority of Democrats who
exist in polls may not be the primary
voters may not be the people who get out
and knock on doors but maybe waiting in
the wings for a quote-unquote moderate
Democrat to take the lead
maybe and there's a good record of this
by the way if Joe Biden is willing to
bet on this there's a good record of
this in the primaries in 2000 lb or one
as the centrist candidate in 2004 John
Kerry was the centrist
candidate in 2008 Barack Obama was a
centrist candidate in 2016 Hillary
Clinton was the centrist candidate
versus Bernie Sanders there's room for
the centrist candidate but will it be
Joe Biden amidst this bevy of jackals I
have my doubts especially with the media
that is not truly thrilled with the idea
of a Joe Biden presidency let's be real
about the media they're in it for the
excitement
hey there on a cocaine hi with Donald
Trump Donald Trump is headlines every
day he's circulation every day do you
think that the media are really that
interested in sleepy joe going up
against Donald Trump or would they
prefer Bernie Sanders or Kamala Harris
or pee bootie judge or somebody new and
exciting and fun to go up against Donald
Trump again I think that this is let's
give joe biden credit where credit is
due this is gonna be the best day of his
campaign and then the day will be over
and we will move on with our lives and
Joe Biden will become at the lead target
of the attacks from all of these people
who are so hysterical for attention
they're willing to endorse any proposal
you think they're gonna hold back when
it comes to Joe Biden I have my doubts
okay time for a thing I like and then
some things that I hate so things that I
like today so Bernie Marcus is the
founder of Home Depot he has a pretty
inspiring personal story Bernie Marcus
basically made himself from from not
much and now runs one of the great
corporations in the United States he cut
a video defending capitalism I know it's
amazing that we now live in this time in
place but Bernie Marcus defending
capitalism is now controversial so
here's Bernie Marcus doing just that
the free market system has been the
biggest creator of wealth and prosperity
the world has ever known
lifting billions of people out of
poverty and far more superior than any
government program could ever be that's
why it pains me to see people in this
country glorifying socialism young
people especially have been
indoctrinated into believing that free
enterprise is immoral because it
enriches the greedy and depresses the
poor while some may say socialism is
well-intentioned the fact is it robs
people of their independence their
dignity and their finances leading to
government dependence suppression of
ideas and lower standards of living for
those under its thumb okay this is
exactly right
now it's amazing Bernie Marcus will be
considered a member of the white
privileged class he was born to Russian
Jewish immigrant parents in Newark New
Jersey he grew up in a tenement he
graduated high school in 1947 he
actually wanted to become a doctor but
didn't have the money to do it
so instead he ended up working for his
dad as a cabinetmaker
and then he studied at Rutgers for a
pharmacy degree he worked in a drugstore
as a pharmacist and then he started
working at cosmetics company eventually
he became the CEO of handy dandy
improvement centers which was a la-based
chain of home-improvement stores and
then he decided after he was fired to
open Home Depot so this is a guy who
basically worked his way through the
system from nothing not even being able
to afford tuition to become a doctor hey
that's a pretty great story of
capitalism capitalism is full of those
sorts of wonderful stories and the fact
that the Democrats refused to embrace
those stories is pretty telling
and pretty terrible so we'll see if Joe
Biden has the has the courage of his
convictions to embrace capitalism we'll
find out Hillary Clinton said that her
embrace of capitalism probably cost for
the Bernie voters
I'll see if Joe Biden has the same
problem okay time for some things that I
hate so speaking of Hillary Clinton she
just won't leave if you are a Democrat
you have to be thinking why why are you
still here why are you hanging around
you you were supposed to win you didn't
win go away now she has an editorial an
op-ed in the Washington Post so they had
Adam Schiff yesterday and Hillary
Clinton today just stellar work
everybody at the Washington Post in
which she talks about the Muller case
and she says our election was corrupted
our democracy assaulted our sovereignty
and security violated this is the
definitive conclusion of special counsel
robert Muller's report it documents a
serious crime against the American
people and the debate about how to
respond to Russia's sweeping and
systematic attack and how to hold
president Trump accountable for
obstructing the investigation and
possibly breaking the law has been
reduced to a false choice immediate
impeachment or nothing history suggests
there's a better way to think about the
choices ahead this is her trying to
defend the fact that she blew the most
winnable election in the history of
America and she blew this thing and that
is because she was a terrible candidate
who did a terrible job
end of story I also loved the idea that
it was Russia's sweeping and systematic
attack that led to her loss wait who was
president when that was happening I
forget now who who
who's the president oh yeah was Barack
Obama what do you do about it did he
stop the sweeping systemic attack on our
elections during the during the campaign
cycle or did he merely unleash people to
investigate Donald Trump in what turned
out to be a giant wild goose chase what
yeah yeah that's what I thought
Hillary says obviously this is personal
for me some may say I'm not the right
messenger but my perspective is not just
that of a former candidate and the
target of the Russian plot I am also a
former senator and Secretary of State
who served during much of Vladimir
Putin's ascent sat across the table from
him and knows firsthand that he seeks to
weaken our country weird didn't Jahannam
a reset button and then allow him to
invade Crimea that was weird I remember
you being there Hillary Clinton I
remember you and the rest of your
Democratic Party mocking Mitt Romney
when he said that Vladimir Putin was our
number one geopolitical foe I recall all
of that but it's personal for her now
once she loses and she goes on like this
complaining about the facts that she
lost the election oh it's because the
Russians because of the Russians again
the Russians did seek to interfere in
the election they interfered in a couple
of different ways the biggest way they
interfered was by using the gusoff ur
2.0 front in order to hack John Podesta
Z mails but that was a bed that Hillary
made and then lay in a Hillary was the
one who decided that she was going to
shield her emails via non-classified
servers that was that was a that was a
Hillary Clinton problem and as far as
the John Podesta emails yeah that
created some bad headlines for Hillary
Clinton she could have outlasted those
if she'd been anything remotely looking
like a decent candidate but she simply
was not she says by the way that the
solution to all of this is that we need
clear-eyed patriotism we have to blame
Republicans also Congress should hold
more hearings hearings would be good and
finally she says that the issue is not
just the president's possible
obstruction of justice it's our national
security and the president is not taking
this stuff seriously enough we need
someone who will so who is that Joe
Biden again Obama was president when all
this was going down a final thing that I
hate today
so taraji Henson and Terrence Howard are
now telling both Disney and Fox that
they want jussie Smollett to be brought
back for empire's next season now I
don't watch Empire so frankly I don't
care and if this is how they want to
sink their show you're welcome to it if
you want to have on race hoax or Jesse
Smollett go for it what will happen is
that the first two episodes will
massive ratings and then there will be a
serious drop-off as people realize they
can't watch a guy who was involved in
beating himself up that's not a thing
they want to do but the fact that actors
think that they can dictate to Disney
how that series is gonna get cast sure
enjoy that see how that works for you
okay well it is the weekend for me
tomorrow there will be more Ben Shapiro
show but it will not be hosted by me
I'll be hosted by I believe Jason Rance
today and Jason Rance tomorrow as well
so you can check out our radio show
tomorrow so enjoy that in the meantime
I'm going to be celebrating the rest of
my Passover holiday and then I will be
back here on Monday where I will be here
for all three hours of the showw podcast
the additional two hours so go subscribe
now now is a great time to do it and
we'll see you then I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wired
production copyright daily wire 20 19
I'm Michael Knowles host of the Michael
Noel's show Joe Biden is in and
according to morning consult he opens
with an eight-point lead not just over
his Democrat opponents but over
president Trump himself we will analyze
2020 than the mailbag check it out of
daily wire calm